trois migrants sont restés 11 jours
assis sur le gouvernail d'un pétrolier à
travers l'Atlantique 11 jours sans
manger sans escale et à la merci des
vagues voilà ce qu'on vécu ces trois
hommes parties du port de Lagos au
Nigéria arrivé au port de Palmas au
Canaries ils ont directement été envoyés
à l'hôpital il souffrait de
déshydratation modérée et d'hypothermie
selon gouvernement canarien l'un d'eux
était dans un état grave considéré comme
des passagers clandestins et non comme
des migrants les trois hommes devraient
donc être renvoyés dans leur port
d'origine selon certains médias
espagnols deux des trois hommes seraient
déjà à bord du même pétrolier qui a la
responsabilité de les ramener dans leur
port d'origine tandis que le troisième
serait encore hospitalisé ce n'est pas
la première fois que ce genre
d'événements se produit aux îles
Canaries depuis 2018 cette situation
similaire ont été enregistrées